Ohio State coach Urban Meyer's stuck on
a cruise ship because of fog hey Niagara
Falls is frozen and the Cleveland Browns
revealed a new logo where the dogs
angrier and the orange is more orange
this is sports without balls
hello again everyone this is marquita
balls dipped it don't do hey sports
without balls fans friends family by the
way I just nailed the intro on would
take and I brushed my hair I'm already
on fire we have a very uh with a special
guest in the studio I am a fan of her
professional work and now i'm a fan of
her personally she has her own podcast
called with special guest lauren lapkus
i just gave it away she's going to
beyond a Jurassic world this summer
which is a soap opera with Dinosaurs you
can see her as a fun security guard in
orange is the new black please welcome
Lauren lapkus yeh yeh hai best intro it
was really good I just I feel I've had
three coffees today and i'm not a big
coffee person yeah are you really jazzed
right now I feel like I feel like I've
got enough fuel for a small village good
sports without balls fans here's what we
got today we got about ten random
stories I'm gonna talk about some sports
that are I might try to see in Los
Angeles this weekend here's what I'm
thinking Lauren you play basketball yeah
I mean that's a stretch but I do try I
am I have a jersey you have a jersey i'm
on a team so let's talk about that yeah
uh you play in a team lady team in los
angeles yes i'm part of the the LA
community league okay which has blown up
over the past couple years I mean it's
getting crazy one of the team's was in
GQ and LA Weekly and all this stuff and
yeah that's just not my team but it was
real placement yes yes everyone plays
yes it's very intense and I'm on the
Kimmy dribblers okay and it was when I
played last season and it was like the
most fun I've ever had in my life I
haven't played since 5th grade but then
this like happened I was like I want to
do except for one's doing it looks fun
and I'm tall so like may well be good at
this or something when I don't know yeah
and it was like the most fun ever and
then in the middle of the season I had
to get my wisdom teeth out and they told
me that my jaw was so thin
because my teeth had grown into my
jawbone because they were really big and
old and weirdly crying they had like
grown it and they had to remove part of
my jaw so they were like if you got hit
in the face of the ball it could break
your jaw which I had been hit in the
face with a ball the night before I got
my teeth out cuz a cool girl was trying
to do a no-look pass and I never heard
of that and I was like slammed in the
face I mean I was like she's going to
them what else then I was like yeah it's
in my mouth it was horrible so I could
have broken my jaw I'm still trying to
visualize how teeth can grow and do your
job they were so um it's like a
Wolverine yeah well they were like they
were normal but then like over time they
sort of like sort of tilting down and
going back and like just smashing and
smashing did you did you feel like like
when you were eating something like like
a like a big sandwich that it was just
like you could get it done in one bite
yeah I mean I've always known that I
couldn't tell anything was wrong I just
like right when I got him removed though
they were like that was very dangerous
like I could have had like nerve damage
from the remote because they were
growing on a nerve it was like insane so
I had to take the rest of the season off
because of my jaw like a baby just so
lame but like I would be the person to
get hit in the face and then I'm coming
back next season though so I'm really
excited so did you have to call the
captain be like listen I got a real
thing yeah yes and what happened was it
like right when I got out of the surgery
like I was still you know I got although
yeah whatever anesthesia and like the
doctor I had casually told him I was
playing basketball before we started as
like small talk I'm like after I got out
of the thing he was like oh and you
can't play basketball anymore and I
burst into tears Oh as I was emotional
yeah I also like it really meant it and
it fired up on trucks yeah i mean i was
totally high but I was also really sad I
was like this the best thing in my life
right now yeah I was like loving every
week I don't work out at all so this was
like my way to get adrenaline in my life
and like I was just devastated I was
like bawling and they were like a little
disturbed because they didn't realize I
cared so much well sports sports teams
like I played on teams my like through
college and I miss I miss it the most
it's so fun like I went to see I'd like
a really shitty back I her needed two
desks playing college basketball
so I have like this absolute fear of
like like I'd shoot around I'll play
like two and two but I have like an
absolute fear of like blowing my back
out again so I went to a couple of
friends it's the same league that I want
to see some games and I turn into like a
like a crazy coach not like the
sidelines and then I literally mapped
out a play during touch I know I should
oh my god what if I like what if I were
just like a like a like an aggressive
like blazer and like a small be amazed a
kitten heel let me so amazing i kiddin
you you could be like the ultimate sub
coach like everyone team who needs a
coach and then you wouldn't have a lot
of commitment and you could just come in
and be like yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] whip
you into shape I can't like I would
sports I can't I get like nothing is
light like there's no like oh yeah you
guys just like go out there and have a
good time I'd be like listen ladies yeah
that's good though I lack under my eyes
I brought us good shots in place all
right so you'll love this story this is
what I mean about it just goes into
tandon's um I've you know have a real
healthy obsession with sports obviously
ever will healthy obsession with women's
basketball there's it's growing the
women's the fandom of women's basketball
is growing so I'm adding so I think that
first league has made me yeah but yeah
and so you know we have the the WNBA
which I have gone to 8,000 games i lived
in new york city like forever and I'd go
see the Liberty at the garden and now I
like I've when I moved to LA it was like
I hate you know I was like born and
raised on the east coast as New Yorker
it's like you're just like you're born
and bred to hate everything LA and now I
love living in Los Angeles and like you
know I'm not gonna cheer for any of the
sports teams but now I'm like all right
I could cheer for the sparks like you
know that's not like you know it's kind
of like you know it's not like I'd ever
become a laker fan I'd rather take us
you know stab out the jugular that's
serious oh yeah I just cheer for
whoever's yeah I man at me yeah I pulled
my hair back and I get real into it and
so I was like all right lady sparks I
can care for so uh you know in lesbo
lady world like you just basically
you'll meet
athlete at some point and someone knows
someone that owes someone and I met and
I've been trying to get around the show
she will get on the show she's playing
somewhere like overseas right now
lindsey harding she's like one of the
starting point cards for the dumpee mba
so she comes to one of my stand-up shows
she brings like a gaggle of other you
know athletes and we have some beers and
I literally took a napkin and I sketched
out what I consider the greatest out of
bounds play of all time oh my god and I
was at the hollywood improv did you make
it up or this was when you would snow no
this is something I learned in a
providence college basketball camp when
I was in like ninth grade because I
moved to Rhode Island when I was 12 a
couple June talks I felt like this is an
exactly what we need to know that yes
yeah yeah how I felt was totally
acceptable so I was with a former
Seattle Storm player now is a coach like
a high school basketball coach in Los
Angeles lindsey harding and another
former at WM a player sort of sauced at
the improv like Ted o'clock mapping out
of play was really receptive to that
they were totally receta died yeah well
I mean cuz we were all like you know
total basketball nerds yeah that's fun
for them from cali yeah and so on the
basketball coach michelle she was like
you know what like first she thought i
was just like being [ __ ] like a dick
not a dick like just being silly yeah
and but i was like you're gonna
understand i was like knowing that and i
think you understand the erin foley
vault and die and then she i legit ibly
mapped out the play and she was like
literally like her expression change and
she was like like really now thinking
can this play work was also oh my you
need to like look for the play in the
future game yes it would that be excited
they did it yeah i was i call it the
foley and then Lindsay sketched out this
crazy out of bounds play that she did
we're basically the ball is out of
bounds you'll get a kick out of this day
all this was like something she didn't
like high school or something they all
line up like straight ahead right the
baskets like here they and they all duck
they all dumb they I kid you not this is
like the starting point card from the
sparks they all jock in the tall one
they throw to the top on and she shoots
that's cool
amazing that's awesome how to sketch out
some place for your team oh my god I
mean we need it we also need you to
write down what does double dribble me
there's some other key things that might
be helpful to yes yeah yeah all of us
are still learning but it's fun what's
really funny because we had this girl
now from Gonzaga who played on Gonzaga
whatever and she's like amazing and so
she's only to denote past me and I was
ok you don't know me yet I can't do this
it's like but um she's incredible but
then yeah we have like a wide range of
abilities yeah it goes from her down to
people who are like I've never touched
basketball yeah it's been it's been
except but it's also really fun to watch
those people get better like that's why
team sports are so exciting to like it's
like a bonding thing and like seeing
someone do well it feels good and and
it's just like such a first of all it's
so fun basketball such a great sport
it's a it's a total like stress relief
oh yeah oh I was the happiest after
every game why we lost by a million over
and I'm like I can do anything I don't
care about any other part of my life I
only play basketball every day and then
I've got knocked out it was over but so
is your is your jaw and full repair that
you can get back on the court I don't
know and I have to call my surgeon
because I'm nervous still because I'm
gonna be shooting a TV show like while
the season is happening I'm like that
would be the worst thing probably ever
break my job during that yeah for
something so not worth it for myself
it's like randomly trying to be good at
basketball and I'm not yeah but so we'll
see we'll see what he says maybe like a
like a helmet maybe like a I already
look like an idiot like I don't know if
I can add that I mean I've thought of
like the goggles you know that whole
look is it's pretty great when you see
someone like just go for it yeah I'd be
all protected yeah maybe we could dad we
could get some sort of soft a jaw helmet
for you like one of those like baby
helmet is like a wrestling no one of the
big ears videos down to the jaw see I
feel like all that stuff is fine if
you're good but then I'm also really bad
and can't make a basket I look like I'm
like mental yeah yeah or you could just
do like a full-blown Silence of the
Lambs ya mouth covering cross eyes I
happen to Laura I'm not well because but
I want to play
I'll will you out with my pencil skirt
I'd have to actually you know there are
some I'm kind of sort of obsessed with
what women's basketball coaches like
we're on the sidelines yeah there is
everybody i think maybe if I haven't
mentioned this a couple there's this a
woman Oh Carol I'm gonna have to need a
i forgot waving we haven't introduced
Lauren to Carol yet uh Carol is my
assistant my fact checker she's a small
drinking problem and so sometimes you
have to wake her up mid podcast cuz she
uh you know what Julie you know what
Carol just discovered Boone's Farm it
smells in here to be honest bring any
snaps to--did she-- Oh to the bottle
pretty hard I which we will discuss lead
you watch the the batch the bachelor
last night yeah oh also I run a fantasy
bachelor League and I don't know if that
relates to sports yeah but yeah it does
you put fantasy you ran you run a
fantasy bachelor League yes oh my god
Carol just woke up she got hamber doing
the bash last night because her favorite
lady got voted off oh mere liye gonna be
okay remind me to come back Julie remind
me we have to come back to this the
coach of Baylor the women's gets like
Kim malarkey yeah something like that
Mulaney Mallette misanthrope she wears
like bright green mat like pantsuit oh
it's amazing horrible different suit
every game um different suits every game
at one time it was so like bit I think
Baylor have some green in their colors
or something like that where I was like
oh wow it's unbelievable but best
college name of a coach muffet mcgraw oh
that's an amazing a Notre Dame and
literally if everyone just googled image
right now Muffet McGraw and you'd say in
your mind I wonder what like a muffin my
bro looks like you'd beat you Dale I
think I know you'd nail I got a bowl cut
yes she's got like a we have to google
image Muffet McGraw right after Lauren
she's got like this little pixie bold
something such a few
Oh totally yeah absolutely that's who I
imagined did you do she's very she's
like doing a model catwalk right now
yeah she's like so that's I love smell
bad but I move forward yeah wait so so
we'll get a guetta the coach of Baylor
if you do like Lady basketball coach
Baylor crazy green suit I think you
could probably google give you google
all those words in a row you'll come up
with something absolutely fantastic
amazing okay wait fantasy yeah this
totally correlates with sports and I'll
tell you why and then you need to tell
me all about it right because of the
word fantasies in it yes and I just
started playing fantasy baseball and I'm
I was talking about this before it I'm
already I don't I don't I didn't need
another job but now it's enough it's I'm
already losing my mind this is a job for
me yeah I put in a good five hours a
week preparing it so if there's
competition it's there's a leak the word
League and fantasy in it so I think this
is like a perfect transition to
wonderful what the hell happened last
night oh my god okay first of all can we
talk about the fact that he said I he
was falling in love with multiple no one
has go ahead I'm falling in love with
you they've never said that they're
always just like thank you post-show i'm
going to show you a series of texts that
i sent to my friend Marissa which we
call the bachelor historian who now
lives in Albuquerque long story and we
texted her isn't that illegal yeah it is
also it's horrible for the girl who was
kicked off because can we say it who
cares right oh yeah mountain gives a
[ __ ] I mean Caitlin was told he loved
her yeah she said I love you he said I
love you to essentially it happened then
he dumped her what three days later yes
okay that's insane Lauren here it is now
granted my friend is a lawyer I said
wait he keeps saying he's falling in
love isn't that illegal her response and
this totally correlates of sports sports
because the first sentence is the ruling
on the field is the ruling on the field
is legal acceptable has happened in the
past when captain Andy I don't know who
that is I guess a former bachelor when
captain Andy was the bachelor a long
time ago he told one of the
final to that he loved her then picked
someone else scandal but yes there is a
precedent for that but I probably
watched the last like six or seven
nobody no one's doing that no that's
like an upset in my opinion the first
second hit of his mouth I was like
what's happening you can't do that right
and I was like well he's in love with
her it's over yeah and then he said to
everyone and then also when you went out
with Whitney he was not into her I was
like yeah like her knee seems so bored
I'm like so like Caitlin oh and I'm
diculous I'm saying he was one hundred
percent over Whitney last night under
present she was his top pick it was
almost like then looking back I'm like
okay so he just knew he loved her so
he's like I don't have to care about
what we do right now I'm pointed that he
was gonna murder and throw over the he
did not like her also she was so orange
her legs were like orange I used to like
her but then the voice the voice I know
it got really cuz he's like I'm really
loving you right now and she's very it's
very not real that's exactly how it's a
yes and I at one point I was like well
I'm not gonna lie i had to open another
bottle of wine cuz I was like I can't
hear that voice can you imagine hearing
that voice the rest of your life on the
roster your life on a farm with no other
people with just like [ __ ] animals
and echoes really bad I alright here's
another thing uh-uh there was just
because I never actually like like and
this is just me I know it's very
rewarding being a wife and mother but
she's like I she's got this fierce job
she loves her job she took him to live
it up place I'm sure job loved showing
it off yeah may almost Wayne him jerk
off into a cup which was embarrassing i
was gonna be like you should and then
she goes test good put it in my narrow
aisle trap him episode four uh so then
she goes oh i'm like half happy right
I've got this big career but like I want
like I'm like okay I'll give you that
yeah but then she's like I'm ready to
throw it every single not away but like
no be done with it be done with it to be
a wife and mom that I'm like hi simple
math you'll still only be half happy
absolutely
I couldn't believe she said that but
then I was like it's the perfect thing
to say he got really excited when she
said that yeah and then you get a virgin
yards Oh whoo here's the thing with bec
i think it's like probably the best fit
because it's either you get some one
that talks so slow she reminds me of
everybody that like starts out the day
like you're like a little bit like okay
like where am I my alarm just walk off
and that's her the entire day yeah that
so she never gets it going no you're
totally right like I know I talk fast
and I'm like a New Yorker but I want to
shake her know she's yeah she's like a
really she's always like processing I'm
telling moving her head back and forth
like squinting like if she if her and I
were watching a sporting event I'd
[ __ ] kill her yeah she'd be like oh
that was a really good play and it would
been like the play would have happened
an hour yeah yeah like you GV like she's
seen but she seems good for him because
she's got nothing really going on for
ourselves yeah as well just latch onto
the farm thing and just be she isn't
she's an empty canvas she's what does
she do what's her job I think she's like
I think her job was for your inner
spirited animal animal enthusiast wasn't
it yeah then dog enthusiast so you have
a dog that's not a job dog enthusiast
and free spirit that was amazing yeah
lily is Lucy that was Lucy's the best
literally like the show is so great talk
talk to me about the lead ok so the
league's very serious um I have 36
members this season haha i had like like
I don't know like 25 last season like I
did last one I did was Juan Pablo and I
took Andy off what is it was too close
oh yeah um but yes and I'm doing this
one again and it was like I kind of
couldn't believe it once it was starting
sits a lot of work I make up all the
rules okay I make up the point system I
do all the math you two off of Matt I
used to everyone send me there were
there points but then it got too tedious
and now since i was adding more people
as I faster if I do the math yeah it
makes it harder for me because I'm doing
more work yeah but yeah it's very
intense and so we're coming up on the
finale I'm gonna do this I'm doing a big
blowout for the finale yeah big deal
yeah wait so how do you is it like is it
does it work like a fantasy league like
everyone gets like
some pic yeah everyone picks five girls
after the first episode when like the
majority are eliminated yeah pick five
and then you get points based on what
they do and I'm we have like a set
standard like standard set of rules for
each week where it's like if they get a
kiss you get 20 points I got this is
awesome if they go in a helicopter you
get to know science if not a lot of
helicopter no I know it was actually
what I usually what am i normal yeah
it's a go tip no.1 every time they say
journey you drank yeah so like now last
night I added a bunch of bonus points
like every time they say the word love
you get points every time someone cries
every time someone's wearing a skirt
like I just throw randomly an era fect
and like um if they have like you know a
ponytail or like sweatpants or they run
and jump and wrap their legs around him
03 / 30 that you would agree which one
did they done gave me a favor and she's
big yeah big lady those shorts I
literally was like is this [ __ ]
Olivia newton-john like it's a trash bag
short supertrash I little it was like
are they is that like something you can
she just feel like that she was gonna
sweat in though they were plastic and
she was in Bali like they both were like
Dench the whole day was like are you a
wrestler trying to make weight what is
happening horrible it was a hot mess it
was bad if she was running at me I duck
I would be like my back's gonna blow out
wait now do you think that they had sex
in the fantasy suite there was some
speculation on Twitter I don't I don't
know all right Stan that okay I think
here's I did posit I was watching with
my friend Renee in candy I did pause it
by the ways I think candy might be in
your fishy in his family because [ __ ]
yeah i just realized when i said kandi I
was like wait I think she was talking
last night about a family she's my
league so kandi Lawrence in reno renege
Gotye oh I know hurt you um so we first
of all it took us seven hours to get
through were just [ __ ] [ __ ] and
we were just laughing the whole time but
that's what it is every Monday whoever
comes over it's just 17 hours and then a
lot of drinking uh but we put I would I
did put it on pause to say okay if we
break this whole virgin thing down if
you lose your virginity in the fantasy
suite on The Bachelor that's [ __ ]
amazing yeah it's kind of an yeah
horrible I mean because what if you
don't get picked and then it's like you
waited your whole life
to do that with some guy you'll never
see again and you only knew for like
eight hours it's still so great well no
it is it's a good story it's better than
like most people I yes yeah losing their
virginity yeah but I just wanted to get
it over with I mean I was like this is
exactly like I'm just stick it in and
that is it the pressure oh I was also a
board 12 kidding yeah like I gotta go
yeah I don't feel good I don't feel safe
about this entire podcast like 20 or
something yeah I was so gay I didn't I
really had no idea if you're like a lady
that sleeps with your softball glove and
then you think about losing your
virginity where you go just get this
hello her what I mean it's like how many
signs do you need I think I was like
putting up like a new york yankees like
wallpaper when I was like just sticking
him I don't know that I feel like it's
something you want to get over with
anyway because the pressure is so
extreme that you're like it yeah good I
know Gary it's weird when we were gonna
be like we're also saying like what if
she bangs him in the fantasy suite and
doesn't tell him oh yeah anywhere she
was a cold fish she just keeps going wow
wow I'm really not everywhere just blood
it's like it just a murder scene and
he's like holy [ __ ] like my dick is so
powerful he leaves being so happy i say
yes i think she went for it what do you
think God I don't know there was a part
of me that thought that she was saying
like I've waited forever for this but
I'm feeling these feelings I've ever
felt like she was leaning toward the
idea of doing it yeah she was sick just
your principles for like two more days
at who marked you're engaged fine yes
yeah I just I just thought if that's how
she loses her virginity it's like it's
like just going out with a bang you
might as well yeah it's like just to
sawed-off shotguns and just like how
we're doing it I mean there's only like
you know 50 women in history who get to
say that they had sex with somebody in
the fantasy suite oh my god might as
well I never want it like I would never
want to be like the gay like
Bachelorette but if I had like three hot
chicks in
the fantasy suite I feel like this is a
great show ever well of course that's
the party doesn't want to end yeah like
I really wish I could keep this part
going longer it's like yeah when you
make three girlfriends and no problems
and like you're in other countries of
course that part's go and you live on a
[ __ ] farm and his life sucks normally
even he can admit it he's embarrassed by
his town he's here he's afraid they all
don't want to live there cuz they don't
cuz no one does yes cuz he doesn't I'm
Brett like the for telling her she's
like I'm ready to move to what does what
does the town called darling fine go
[ __ ] yourself that's Arlington I'm ready
to move to Arlington has never been said
ever ever know ever no one has said that
they just are there yeah you're there
and they're like I'm a meth head or like
just I'm I'm just like I I there's no
way out you have to be born into it yeah
yeah listen nothing i'm sure there's a
lot of good sports fans northington i
apologize it's listening keep people
singing arlington i'll give you listen
I've done stand-up and I don't want to
brag des moines dubuque and see Darrell
give you Dubuque des moines fun for a
weekend dubuque absolutely gorgeous
right on the river cedar rapids okay
next story stop it stuff Cedar Rapids
it's a little tunnel um alright so the
jaws gonna get replaced yeah I mean it's
regenerating their self currently th I
don't thank you mister what it's for
every other athlete everyone who can't
see she's holding it up for me right
she's really pushing it I don't feel
good I bring me nervous I bring a stage
to all the new guests on the show I mean
it's a great gift just to see if you
want to take this next hour up a knock
it just start mainlining HGH great I
mean that I that's the I think my bones
are building themselves back up but
that's a kind of a creepy thought and
also I don't believe it so I'm just kind
of waiting to see what happens I hope
you get back on the court me too i'm an
alternate now because they added some
like legit players so I was like yeah
since I don't know what's gonna happen
me I'll yeah just be there when I can so
what is is the league competitive like
I'm good there's some good play yeah
every team has like a few really good
people yeah and some teams are
just really good yeah across the board
so I feel it's very competitive
regardless of how good you are yeah well
just get really into it and that's how
people get hurt too because they don't
know what they're doing yeah and like a
lot of times it's like people who don't
really play it but there it competitive
sounds like elbows everywhere being
crazy fouling and her example and I know
that's when I like I get super like I
want to play but I get super nervous
like oh mah god what if I go down I know
it could happen that's what I get
injured like I get so competitive and
then I get a like I hurt my back in
college and then it I felt better so I
was like I'm gonna play uh I'm gonna
play floor hockey cuz you know that was
cool and I played like just floor hockey
just for the fun of it and I was talking
to my mom I was like mom and I go play
floor hockey I'll call you back this is
like senior of college she goes oh here
and be careful with her back I was like
nothing's gonna happen call her back up
as I need your insurance information
she's like what happened I go uh someone
I stick my face and I broke my nose oh
so it's something will happen if I join
that league yeah I'll like accidentally
break your John feel horrible someone's
gonna I'll give you a no-look pass god
that was horrible I would've been cool
if I caught it would have been amazing
it was very uncool how it hit my face
and I was shocked and everyone on the
sideline was gasping that's horrible
though it didn't look neat I'm sure they
don't bleep idiot I was like I'm very
competitive like idiot can't play this
game did you grow up like so you grabbed
playing some basketball did you like wat
was it a where did you grow up outside
the Chicago in Evanston ok Western yeah
um my dad and brother are very into
basketball so I always watched it yeah
we went to games like I saw Michael
Jordan play at school at that's exciting
that was neat when I was on my fifth
grade team of my dad coached that and oh
my god we make your dad coaching was
intense tit was he like cooler was he
like screaming he's cool but he's
intense he's like he's like like just
serious yeah he had one of those
clipboards with the dye oh yeah and the
whole deal and we didn't know what the
[ __ ] he was talking about but we went
along with it um and I had a sweet spot
I could make any point and he shot from
the side the three-point kind of line I
mean it's a small gym for kids so it's
probably a lot closer but straight to
the side that's your shot yeah
nice yeah I don't have one now I just
keep missing but I got so close to my
goal is to score basket every game this
season thinking that was realistic yeah
and then once I was on the court I
couldn't do it all and it was sad yeah I
mean I had to quit eventually so it was
over but sis practice yeah I'm not there
and shooting around it would been so
thrilling to make a point I would have
been thrilling well I mean listen going
into next season with your jaw helmet I
you gonna you're gonna shoot around come
over to Silver Lake where do you live in
this Los Angeles in studio city and
studio said but yeah I'll go anywhere we
have I've got a court by my house I've
got a whistle oh yeah I have three
basketballs tour deflated one is ready
to go you just 6am Lauren ooh we're
gonna do this ooh 730 078 make it later
eleven o'clock one PS see you there
won't be I'm tomorrow we're shooting
hoops all right let's continue with some
basketball stories did you get into
march madness at all no I but I think
that would be fun I like competing and
stuff so fun I just didn't ask her pool
and without knowing anything and i won I
was really excited but it was so low
stakes $15 that I that's plenty what's
enough but I like a point like John
Travolta was manhandling every single
person God his hands on her face well
first of all qui just take one more
second to do this is the most pop
culture evolved sports podcast I love it
Scarlett Johansson you like Sarah look I
loved her look I didn't really like it i
like the room did she shave her head she
shouldn't know if you say she was
beautiful she could pull off anything
yeah I didn't really like the dress the
game chandelier yeah it was like a lady
version of green lantern mmm hi I'm a
suckfest of all I have a blonde problem
and I am a sucker for that haircut that
Erica oh my god cool I mean that really
shows that somebody has a lot of
confidence she does have a lot of God
that's what I would first say about
Scarlett Johansson I feel like she's got
a lot of confidence it was like she
thinks she's pretty it's almost like she
walks on stage with the grad green
chandelier and she's like this is gonna
go well I think
Oh God people like me and she just had a
baby in her hip she just had a baby yeah
her waist I mean yeah she had a baby her
unless I was I live under a cave under a
cave orange I have then you really don't
know what's going have you ever lived
under a cave there's I'm now wondering
if I'm right about her baby I might have
made that up Carol get up off the ground
take out your night guard and look this
up my god I don't know why she is one
hour of day of work and she's literally
on the couch napping I mean it's
pathetic she was so distraught over the
bachelor last night first of all Caitlyn
needs to come on the show who do you
think is gonna do you think she's gonna
be the new bachelorette boy the cruise
ship singer maybe oh do you know that
the cruise ship singers a brother was on
Andy season what he was Zack and he was
like plastic surgery looking kind of guy
where and he was saying me songs and he
was very like devil yeah her brother and
she was in an episode they went to his
hometown and she was at the house and
they sang a song to Andy together you
can look up the video Oh might know I
remember seeing this and she was the
singer her baby's name is rose she did
have a baby did have a baby Scarlett
thank you Julia Rose goes with Scarlett
that's what I was like like Scarlett is
red I'm sorry Rosa so lame it's so lame
that's my news what if i just said have
a not even though no a female name was
ribs he's like I'm so sorry it's
actually really goes by with Lauren the
first article is Scarlett Johansson
breast pump a backstage no Edna awards
Scarlett look she's got Johansson
breasts from Baja in the Oscars I think
she is confident I still i'll post the
screen oh that's amazing you know what
else is amazing our next story great
this is a greatest transition of all
time all right so Kansas Kansas blade
Kansas State in a college basketball
game last night that I it randomly
watched the end of it just
flipping around trying to find clippers
memphis as you do when you've got this
problem I and I'll show you the video
there is a big court storming incident
meaning you know as as people are known
to do they storm the court after after a
win but this one was actually quite
quite scary I'm going to pull up the
video uh now here we go it's loading I
just want to show this video to Lord
because I I like a good court storming
but this is crazy here we go roll on the
tape first of all it's so fast is that
normal yeah this is not on fast-forward
so everyone is you know rushing the
court as they do but look what the crazy
thing is the coach for Kansas Bill Self
got like pinned up against the
scoreboard one a whole fan tried a
chicken wing uh one of the Kansas
players it feels really unsafe to be
able to go so close to the players right
as terrified it's terrifying they rush
the court so quickly and now here's the
two still videos okay so K State Police
tweeted k state police would like help
identifying this fan send a tip at blah
blah blah blah or call this number and
we'll post Julian I will post this this
clip but here's a guy he's literally he
rushes under the court and the camera
caught him beelining towards the Kansas
fan and what they called chicken winging
I don't know flinging his arm out to hit
the Kansas player he looks insane he
looks insane what like what are they
gonna do to him they want to arrest but
probably they could literally probably
if the Kansas player wanted to charge
him with assault yeah well I think this
quote is funny it's a ball game it's not
about chicken winging somebody when the
game's over first of all I had never
heard the term chicken wing it's so
casually thrown into that sentence we're
just chicken Wang Ying this guy I mean
it looks like
I don't know it to me looks like an
accident but I can't some not a moving
image so I can't tell well the moving
image is this guy running in his
direction and throwing an arm at that's
so it was like it was definitely like he
was going for this play why is he doing
that when he's excited that they won why
is he knocking him down well no that's
the enemy Oh Kansas State fan it was at
a home game for Kansas State and this is
a Kansas State fan clipping the kansas
guard i'm honestly still confused are
there to Kansas teams there's Kansas
State it's Kansas and they played each
other and they've liked each other
they're like big lie you know how many
people are gonna tweet oh my god they
hate it like they hate each other I mean
it's like Cubs and Sox I get it yeah
it's like Cubs and Sox and the thing is
Kansas do I get it I don't know yeah
acting like I did it totally cool um
Kansas is always like the better team
not every year but let's say nine out of
ten times nine out of ten years Kansas
is always dominate Kansas State never
really beats them never I mean there's
been times but so this was like the
craziest rivalry you know and this is
why the melee happened that is crazy at
first I was like ow court storming
whatever but this video I just was like
oh my god like they're they're going
after the players and also can you just
imagine like I don't like anyone right
running at me and oh but there's so many
people and they're all [ __ ] probably
drunk and crazy that it's really scary
speaking of running at people this is
nothing to do with anything the other
day I was at UCB sunset which was like
really dark windows and I saw my friend
walking into the place and then I opened
the door I know he couldn't see me so I
ran at him and screamed and he was so
scared and it was so fun I never get to
scare anyone in my life I'm usually
really scared of everything so I had a
great time he hated it and he's like 6'5
and like was like ooh it was great
that's awesome yeah i hope he shot his
pan I chicken winged him all night and
then I chicken winged Adam I think maybe
um I was thinking about this today I
think I think I've this point have
probably bothered me like 10-15 years
ago but as I get older I I'm finding
myself turning into
Mary Foley who was my mother Mary Agnes
Kathleen waters Foley long name and she
is was a professional a schoolteacher
and now but before that in our entire
life she was a professional anxious lady
and worried about I don't know just
anything she can worry about and now i'm
slowly morphing into a lot of anxiety
and worry and when I saw this clip I was
like oh god there's too many people many
people running too many people attacking
people like I got all [ __ ] Mary fully
wound up was there put in your life
where you would have stormed the cord I
could probably I could probably start my
car tomorrow ok so it's just part of you
that's starting to be but i don't think
i'm not a fan that is gonna like run and
like run and scream and like like being
addressed like I wouldn't do that
because I don't want to get caught in
the middle where there's no exits yeah
that's like a safety however this is
what I would storm I would storm this
summer I'm going up to i'm performing at
like a yuk yuk's it's like an improv
chain but it's in canada in toronto and
then I'm staying in Canada for the
Women's World Cup I would storm that
field I'd storm the field I hope you do
I would run out into the field and try
to make out with Ali Krieger she is the
back linebacker you should do it during
halftime so you're the only one and then
you have more of a shot I'd like to run
out and go we should totally make out
although I think she's making out with
the goalie whatever well I hope solo the
backup goalie lesbians there must be
more exciting like a team drama among
the women's teams total I would assume
well I'm always fascinated like you know
everyone just thinks like so many like
women's athletics are all filled with
gay ladies yeah they're not it's
actually a smaller it's like a you know
listen do I want everyone to be gay yes
well I mean just professional athlete
but it's actually just a small
percentage but the ones the ones that
are like lesbos get real obsessed over
yeah it makes sense exciting yeah and
some of them are so of course everyone's
like are what are your errand what are
your goals for stand-up comedy and I was
like wow
to play catcher Derek Jeter uh to shag a
women's professional soccer player both
are my goals I mean I'm well on my way
no more famous you get the more likely
it is for both of those things yeah
they're like oh you should start a
podcast and then it'll get popular and
you get more road work and I was like no
I'm gonna start a sports podcast so i
can start ragging professional athlete
yeah get him on does it happen no not
even close let's talk about this fun
story um I'm gonna always yes did you
see this lady's tattoo I did I actually
knew this woman because I think we may
be highlighted her in an earlier sports
without balls episode during the
Olympics Olympic weightlifter Holley
Mangold by the way her brother is the
Center for the New York Jets Nick
Mangold and they sort of they look like
they could be twins but she's like a
crazy amazing weightlifter she l case
she is unorthodox career she played
playing offensive lineman in her high
school football team amazing whoa
competing on Biggest Loser I didn't know
that cool and mtv's true life what is
true life about that's like when true
life i'm addicted to my phone or
something oh that's mine true life and
I'm a dude to life I I'm cheating on my
girlfriend or something and then it
shows like a story of different people
who are doing that thing or something I
want I want you to host you're show the
subject it to my father and this is me
playing on my phone for 30 I'm just like
I'm like I'm not even looking at cuz I
did go to one on her phone what do you
what he watching true life hi okay so
okay so she did the 2012 london olympics
i realized that this is more of a visual
and this is a podcast however we can
we'll post the visual but on the side
she shaved this out of her head and
tattooed the olympic rings and she I
think sort of pulled it off I think so
too it's sort of like goes with her face
I think it's kind of cool and her hair
can grow back and I just like a cool
secret you have a total cool secret so
we pulled it up right now the Olympic
rings so that would be pretty awesome
if the hair grows back and then she's
like on a date and then she's like boom
big reveal do you think her hair is
gonna grow all those different colors
out of the whole lot of the word just
came or if they're just came out of the
Rings hahaha she just she just kept
shaving around the Rings and let the
hair go through the Rings oh awesome Oh
already discussed and amazing I think
that's it I'm we're gonna tweet at
Holley Mangold and say just grow your
hair out through the Rings Julia get at
it she looks like she could also play
center for the New York Jets ish I mean
that's a cool family that's a great
family or a success because I totally
want to tweet at her about that hair you
need her to reply we need her to reply
immediately and show us an update of the
of the spot seriously though like that
would be the funny thing ever yeah and
she just grew the hair out it'd be
really cool no one's ever had a hair
tattoo feel that subtle music you know
what's the greatest thing about the
Olympics and people like say 20 things
at her she's like no my hair boom check
it out gold medal I mean it i think
that's a cool way to commemorate that
too though it's amazing if you keep
making more problems for yourself right
if that's right that's what's happening
boom i'm gonna green-light that what
we're saying um I forgot this other
basketball story listen we're gonna
we're gonna come back how are we doing
that time what it feels like we just got
started eyeing bye ok this is this is
one of my favorite ok cuz we're gonna do
seminars I'm just kidding Lauren just
put me off um ok this is a this is why
don't know why we didn't start with this
is because I don't know things happen
this is a fun story it's not a fun story
uh it's just interesting prep teams
banned from post-season ok this story I
actually kind of love to high school
teams in lady uh high school teams I
think that's what you say I think it's
called women's basketball teams 80
ballers lady small ballers in Tennessee
they're playing each other the winner
plays their trend that they're getting
in
the postseason the winter play is like
the best team if they win and these two
teams decide they're going to both not
like they're going to tank purposely
tank so they can lose so they can play
another team in the postseason and
apparently it got so bad that they were
shooting air balls dribbling like off
themselves shooting the of at the other
team's basket yeah I mean those are all
things that happen to my games all
sounds like they're doing it well I
don't know Wow Laura escort for the
other team but she's so bad I mean this
is so bad that's him that is amazing and
there was like a video of them like kind
of how it's horribly so bad it would be
hard to do something to do badly if
you're good I mean also i feel like i
would feel bad i mean that was one of
the things that the sportscasters were
talking about that it was like yeah that
they that that's like goes against the
whole I mean one of the game like don't
sabotage yourself yeah I mean I just
think it'd be hard to purposely lose men
that went you're if you're actually good
at the thing I mean yeah also it's like
that's the worst that is the worst
lesson you could possibly teach a child
your best isn't good enough next round
yeah so just like for just purposely
tank it's like you know not to be
dramatic but like this like these games
like they and and just sports in general
and in you know elementary school in
junior high and high school that they
shape humans they shape these women
especially women and that age group it's
so tumultuous it's like your self-esteem
is connected to like your [ __ ] lunch
yeah and now let's go out and tank the
game no and then they were going to get
in trouble and then the coaches we're
trying to say like they should the girls
shouldn't get in trouble on the coaches
chigan no they should all they should
all be in trouble and they were they
were bana okay they were banned from the
postseason well which i think it's the
oh yeah wait I wrote this down um it's
the Tennessee what is it what is it like
Tennessee well I wrote it down another
page oh yeah PS SI es SI t ssa which is
like Tennessee School Association for
athletics
something like that and I thought well
that Tennessee basketball association
should be in charge of the NBA because
the seventy Sixers have been tanking for
about four years under Oh Knicks just
started tanking they sent was it cheap
schubert I can never pronounce his name
right and my boy oh what's his name
Carol I tatted Julia look this up the
two oh my got it Jerry Smith wow wow
that was almost a moan wrenched you guys
have just passed out I just woke up how
long was I out for a long time and you
just said JR smith repeatedly over I
don't know the Knicks just sent half
their teams to clean now are these
people who are just doing poorly I'm I
just I want to follow what you're saying
we're not purposely doing bad they're
just so ya know they're purposely doing
that for visiting bad ok so they're bad
right but they're purposely doing more
bat which is actually bright great
English yeah to get better draft picks
and this is like a trend now it's like
okay we know we're crappy we're in like
the cellar let's just ship like there
was there's only two or three may be
fairly good players on the next left
shipped him to Cleveland for [ __ ] bag
of donuts in my mom and now they're like
oh an 89 but I hate that yes so I'm
saying the Tennessee TS SSA should be in
charge if I were I feel like I wouldn't
even want to go play the game if i knew
i was gonna have to just pretend to be
bad like the thing is i think they're
sort of trying but they're like the
seventy Sixers notorious and actually in
the ESPN magazine i just came out this
huge article on so so the seventy Sixers
essentially in the last couple of years
have been so bad they keep shopping out
the players they but they're saying it's
like this this long long term plan which
I don't think they have any plans to
like keep losing they don't want this to
happen but they realized they just went
in the complete other direction they
could have been like
pretty like okay but they kept taint
like they've literally been purposely
tanking and they just sent one of their
stars who wasn't playing like to full
capacity for another second round draft
pick so now they have 15 second round
draft picks in the next like a couple of
years and they're like we're going to
turn it all around but in the meantime
purposely tanking yeah I don't like it I
don't like it can you tell them I don't
like it can we tweet at the 76 Lauren
does not like it I mean I don't I barely
know what's happened but I don't like
you I don't like it the Tennessee later
I enjoy your sand the Tennessee ladies
can't play in the postseason the 76er
should be dis be disbarred yes they
should not be able to practice law next
year um by the way quick shout-out uh to
women's women's basketball South
Carolina just beat Tennessee last night
I taped it I haven't seen it yet but
well I even though I know the outcome
yeah I respect that I just want to throw
one stat out for the Gamecocks how do
you feel about that man yummy when I say
Gamecock what do you think Lauren Oh big
dick on game day just on game day I mean
Gamecocks that's a bad name horrible I
mean no matter when that name was
created they knew what they were do they
know you know you know who was not
involved in naming that women I mean
come on come on one time I performed at
a college it's no longer I think they
changed it but it was like one of my
first colleges i went to to perform and
it's like when you have to like you get
thrown into it and you're like have to
do an hour and you probably have like 17
minutes of material not a crowd work and
so you're like you like take the school
newspaper and you're like run with it
you ask like seven hundred questions
about the school and you try to talk to
everyone to like blue diamond but their
mascot was the Blazers as in suits as in
ibly as
of a piece of all the piece of clothing
you can't that is not and because I'm
not intimidating it was like a business
school at one point in time and I was
like well I was like how your sports
teams are like we're not very good yeah
cuz you're a blazer no that's horrible
horrible like the flip flop what are you
doing I hate it one two three flip-flops
kill yourself no yeah my middle school
was the north star isn't even that
doesn't sound like anything I like I
like an animal mascot personally the
North Stars yeah would we got we lead
the way I just made that up I don't know
if that wasn't our motto when we're all
abandon at sea we're still northern us
we'll just look up and we'll get back to
land yeah gamecocks oh Christ that does
not make me let's say I got a full ride
to the University of South Carolina I'd
be like I'm gonna pass you don't want to
be a Gamecock nope never did never feel
comfortable with the word [ __ ] hence I
want to never mind okay I hold on all
right so this is like just a really fun
stat oh my god I hope I printed out both
pages um the reason why I'm follow South
Carolina I don't really trip for South
Carolina the reason why I am is because
dawn staley who played in the Olympics
an amazing basketball player is now the
coach of care South Carolina they have
not literally beat there were some stat
that's gone on this page oh yeah no it
is it is okay Monday's game for South
Carolina it's the first win over the
lady vols that's the whole Pat Summitt
Tennessee team in Columbia meaning in
columbia south carolina since warlick
network was the coach the new coach of
Tennessee was a senior guard as senior
mean senior lauren teen right after
junior since senior guard as in you know
secure guard word orange in news but
yeah for Pat sarmet January 23rd 1980
they have not won they had not beaten
that team in south carolina since 1980
and they won last night that's exciting
that's
none of them were alive the last time
now they were just they were just they
were thoughts they were like maybe
someday I'll have a kid maybe someday
I'll [ __ ] Phil and have it to have a
little game talk of my own um I want to
send a couple shout outs okay we've got
two more okay very good time for a
couple more a couple fun stories we've
got a boxing story I wanted to do a
Twitter shout-out and then one of my
favorite stories this week Michael Sam
my beloved pink clad adorable NFL player
my gay boy who needs to deserves another
chance in the NFL decides to compete on
Dancing with the Stars do you watch the
shrill or I don't um I and what the
problem is that i read a navy article
yesterday AV Club article that was like
talking about the new people and half of
them were joke names and I really I left
not knowing who was really on the show
so I I rented like a really
uninformative article um was it on the
onion yeah but I mean it was at the
onion is AV Club they were just around
there just effing her that's my news
source I only no joke according to AV
Club were at war with China um okay so
Sam uh Michael Sam here's the thing
here's what I'm nervous I'm nervous I
want Michael Sam to get like another
shot in the NFL he wants to get another
shot at the NFL I don't know if this is
the best move does that what what does
this do in your mind make some more okay
okay so they don't want him to be gay
well I do think that's not part of the
image they're trying to project I think
the NFL are obviously it's just like
this you know it's my favorite sport but
it's I mean if we're being honest with
ourselves it's a pretty huge homophobic
yeah tution right it was he came out
yeah and the in event had like rumor
central the only reason why the st.
Louis Rams even took him in the sixth
round is because like the commissioners
like twinkle in the sixth round so any
gets bounced around listen it might not
be that he's at the level i mean i don't
know i'm not an NFL coach it's just that
he was the number one defensive player
in the SEC his senior year of college so
you think why is he out now because they
think he play
is like a like a defensive lineman like
but at the end like a defensive end and
they think he's like too small and not
quick enough which totally could be
however I find it hard to believe that
he didn't even make he made like to
practice squads and then got cut really
SEC Player of the Year when people leave
it leave do they come back is that like
normal for someone to like not be
playing for a while then come back and
play it's well it's a it's a it's a
rarity I think it's like every year
people just try making try and make a
try my but you see you hear a lot of
stories including in the Super Bowl
which I actually can't believe I'm
bringing up because I try to block it
out the the receiver who I'm blanking on
his name from Seattle who caught like
four big catches in that game was
working at like a supermarket three
months earlier I mean is that crazy now
that's wrong but it's something just
like that haha so you hear stories of
people getting plucked out of nowhere
you know to mean that are like on
people's radars but so I'm just saying
like I want Sam to be in the NFL do you
do dancing with stars before you try
your second around and I don't maybe
he'll show them how quick he is by his
little dance box is red listen I nailed
the foxtrot I'm ready for the NFL I want
I just feel like I get like you know a
little gay protective yeah and uh I
don't know but I think he'll be a good
person to watch it's gonna be so fun
yeah you watch that show I don't but I
watch them so you think you could dance
mmm which I it's just basically me
crying it's just it's so emotional no
well so yeah sort well no I mean it's
like it's full yeah dance like it
already on it and they get kicked off if
they don't do it snow like they jazz
hands competition but like it's like
dancing like people vote people off and
you do a little performance or how does
it go um yeah but these these guys are
like fierce professional dancers and you
know there's like two outlets for
professional then yes and so in and so
there that the level is like
unbelievable and they do like every
different type of dance and then there's
three judges usually one maybe once a
celebrity now and then but it's usually
three like you know X dancers and
basically you just you just cry the
pieces are so moving right Julie shaking
your head did you what you watch it I
have yeah surprise ET rest Chad
Ochocinco was actually on Dancing with
the Stars and so was Emmitt Smith yeah
there's been a budget oh yeah 11 hines
ward 1 din hines ward win ooh i can look
that up but yeah so maybe that one
really good yeah i don't think it'll be
as- is no i don't think i think it's
great for the show and for fans I'm just
I'm like does this mean while I'm just
thinking in football translates I'm just
a football terms as usual okay here's
some other people on Dancing with the
Stars Suzanne Somers Oh Patti LaBelle
wow how old is she 89 that's not right
62 Oh 48 I know I meant I meant that's
not right for her to be on not that
you're incorrectly I'm not like an eight
Warren just yelled at me because I
didn't know Patti that's wrong get it
correct uh heart tank investor alert
robert herjavec i watch shark tank
regularly wits chart what is which ones
charge time it's people who have a good
idea for a product and they've tried to
sell it or making make a big go of it
your face and volume just changed which
is hilarious my to just go people they
want to show people who have a good idea
for a product and they come onto the
show and they've already tried to make
their business okay put me back then
these sharks invest in their products oh
I get it their business off the ground
okay so yeah I've got a good idea for
shark tank I want to be the wide
receiver for the New York Giants does it
work like that go in there and pitch it
to them okay former NFL players I've got
it right here Donald Driver Hines Ward
and Emmitt Smith are among the past
winners Wow well hines ward I think wide
receivers have amazing footwork did you
know Lynn Swann and the 70s took up
ballet lessons I didn't know that put
that in your pocket try to use it this
week in a conversation I can't wait it's
gonna be very alienating if I alienating
she means bringing people haha
okay last story this is a fight like I'm
not I don't watch a lot of boxing uh but
mayweather pacquiao there we haven't I
haven't talked about this I'll probably
talk about this at an ad nauseam going
up to the fight it's May second it just
it just mats in the last week or two and
I I'm so strangely excited for this
fight do you watch are you a boxing no
but I think that I know people who are
named I can't Mayweather's blank all
right so these guys but here's here's my
favorite part of the story all right
well there's two parts the reason why I
pulled out the story is because this
week I took off this weekend probably
cuz i've done a turn freaking chosen
lesson eight or two nights but long
story a friend i'm helping some people
move one of them is moving into my
apartment my twin sister cool that's
another story it's fine it's fine my
twin is moving our new identity of three
cats it's not really how I envisioned
that's gonna things rolling out but it's
gonna be fine I love that you should
make a sitcom about that yep called wow
this is this is how it all shut down so
I was like right so moving some stuff
this week and I was like okay I've got I
never have like nights off so I was like
well I'm gonna see you know some
sporting events UFC now I'm not like the
biggest Ultimate Fighting thing but a
fan but Ronda Rousey is like the
fiercest fighter so I was like in there
and they that matches start at like 330
at the nokia center on Saturday night so
I was like I'm gonna go see it with my
friend Nia who's married to bill burr
and i watch i go over bill and Nia's
house and watch UFC and the tickets are
insane like the tickets are nosebleed
seats which which you would never pay
like you can't be that high to watch
like naturally little it's like playing
when I was punching robot games exactly
I was almost going to introduce the
stories this is story about punching
robot you can't like so it's like a
hundred dollars just to even like get in
the building and I was like and rot
Rousey armbars her opponents it's gonna
be over literally in it like a minute or
less than a minute and I'm like all
right so then I look at Lakers are
playing the Thunder which are probably
gonna go say hit the Lakers wherever I
wouldn't say the Thunder on Sunday I go
on the Lakers website and the tickets
are outrageous yeah I'm listening I'm
gonna go to I'm gonna go to step up
aside or a coppers game it's cheaper no
I love the Clippers but they're away all
week but the point of this is the ticket
to get in to see Floyd Mayweather and
Manny Pacquiao this guy from ESPN Las
Vegas reports to get ringside tickets to
Floyd Manny you must have at least a two
hundred fifty thousand dollar credit
line to MGM to even get consideration
250 and then someone tweets back my bro
mark Spitzer 35 years in las vegas
casino business says the person must be
willing to pay the full 250 thousand
dollars not just have the wine why would
you ever do that even if i had $250,000
even being like such a major sports vamp
I would never I cannot imagine anything
i would spend that amount money on even
if that was nothing to me let's say
every day I wiped my ass with $250,000
I'd buy a yacht but seriously like I
would pay like I pay the only thing I
really blow money on is like if I'm
going to a major sporting event which is
all the time I will do i'll drop I'll
drop it I'll wear the same effing shirt
for a year and I'll drop like two
hundred dollars no sporting event but
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
it pay-per-view ninety dollars all right
that's crazy but if like four people
come over you pass the Hat well that's
true if that's the only way that makes
sense here's the thing if I let me let
me get your opinion on this and then
we'll do feel good moment week let's say
I invite people over to a pay-per-view
event for UFC boxing whatever like i'll
i'll pay the ninety dollars of people
over yeah i would never charge anyone i
was at two more like in the last couple
years they're like oh yeah like come
over it was like a forty-dollar like
event they're like everyone chip in like
twenty bucks I was like are you ready
like I'm know
oh yeah if you're hosting an offering
today something I do think you should be
prepared yeah too if someone says hey
let me throw in a couple bucks if you
want to accept it I feel like that's
acceptable I'd be like bringing some
beer yeah I mean I literally was like I
she bona well I think I $90 event yeah
is a lot in general yeah but what if you
what if you had a bunch of friends come
over and then they each put in two
dollars and then it paid for it yeah
you'd have to bring 45 people whatever
you guys 45 days or something I guess
ask well I just feel like if your whole
no no i don't and i said twice it only
happens once i only have a one time and
I was a little outraged because it was a
friend of Mines boyfriend who was loaded
well that was that's rude if you have a
lot of money it's rude don't ask for it
also if it's forty dollars for the thing
come it's also negligible shuttling
right along knowing can I hold him on
the phone yeah I heard you have a lot of
money cheap ass hi Lauren its shed
listen I like to save money on my yacht
suck it suck it Chad everyone talks [ __ ]
about you that day first of all of your
name okay Mayweather is 38 years old
Pacquiao 36 years old ah maybe I can get
back on the basketball court okay yeah a
couple Twitter shout outs and then
feel-good moment of the week um Kelly
DeSalvo s period andrew de salvo andrew
is it andrew is it s um be clear they
did thank me over Twitter for not
[ __ ] on Orlando apparently a [ __ ]
out Orlando a lot i gave you Jameer
Nelson last week one of my favorite poet
cards ah thank you for tweeting at me is
what I'm saying and look at this the
entire podcast nothing bad about Orlando
Orlando [ __ ] suck I would never lose
their what Lauren that was that was not
me Evans Simon tweeted at me to Cuban
players i went to i was in Puerto Rico
and I want to see the Caribbean world
series based I actually didn't Evan I
didn't see Cuba Puerto Rico play I'd saw
Dominican dominica Dominican Republic
it's fine
everything's gonna be fine I started
taking republic play Venezuela and also
we I have had a running joke with a
friend of mine how when Cuba plays
anything internationally always there's
always people defecting they would
literally defect wherever they are and
we wanted to shoot a video where I was a
sports reporter and I was in the was in
the dugout after the game the Cuban
dugout and known was there there was no
an interview because they all had
defected so anyway thank you for
tweeting that at me um oh also Tiana I
apologize i can't i'm gonna give it my
best shot Tiana Nakasone a nak ASO any
what would you say to that na ka SOA
knee raucous own sure I just made her an
Italian nakasone egg I don't know the
meatballs uh she said she yells and
Yeltsin scripts of the TV of
motivational remarks during sporting
games she wondered if I did that yeah
yes it's why I don't watch sports in
public I'm a [ __ ] lunatic feel-good
moment of the week Lauren we end every
episode with a feel-good moment of the
week cuz you put on the news and you
just cry and hold yourself in a corner
besides your jaw getting better which
could be a feel-good moment of the week
I will queue up the we don't even need
to see the video but we'll put the video
up at Facebook um right before the NBA
all-star game happened about a week ago
so it's a feel-good moment that just
sort of got publicized but did happen
about 10 days ago if anyone writes in
and says it didn't happen this week stop
listening to this podcast my favorite
NBA player is Stephan curry he plays for
the Golden State Warriors I'm I've been
obsessed with him since he started since
college mm-hmm during the the all-star
game he met a Monet Davis do you
remember Gino Monet Davis if you if you
saw a picture like you would recognize
her that's the the the little girl for
the Little League World Series last
summer made the huge splash she was the
only one girl to win a little league
world series game she Paige oh yeah her
like sports sports kit of the year
her she's amazing yeah so her even
though she grew up in Philly because the
76 or suck and they tank she's her
favorite players curry I guess what I'm
saying is I'm obsessed with Mona Davis
I'm obsessed with Stephan curry I love
that Mona Davis is like f the seventy
Sixers she was wearing a golden state
t-shirt there's a video which we will
post Stephan curry goes over I started
crying Stephan curry goes over meets
Monet Davis my head almost fell off
tears sweet tears of joy down my face
and he asked her for her autograph oh
that's so nice it was so sweet that's
really cute I mean and it like she was
just like trying to like act composed
and he was like he had the Sports
Illustrated where she was on the Sports
Illustrated cover and she's signed and
then they started shooting together my
head almost fell on it so he isn't the
cutest thing ever yeah we'll post the
video if you could shoot with anyone
just jump shots obviously besides me
because we're going to start practicing
hardcore I'm so scared who would it be
it doesn't have to be a basketball
player just could be a human this I
don't know why this popped my head it's
not my answer but I feel that I have to
tell you because it makes no sense yes
but Barney the Dinosaur so you you and
Barney the Dinosaur I don't know why he
was in there immediately shooting
baskets the second you said if you could
play with anyone so I guess I'll stick
with that little arms I'd like to see
him try yeah little dinosaur arms maybe
he would just you just be doing some
weird layups he won't be able to pick up
the ball no you'd have to hand him the
ball it would be a shitshow I think it'd
be fun it would be a real real long day
of shooting and everyone be like is he
still relevant why we why is he here is
he does he sell the show I don't know
what if he would have Barney the
Dinosaur your spirit animal oh I would
make sense I'd be amazing can I just say
for 30 seconds I dated this lady it was
short-lived she went to like a tarot
card reader or some specialist alpha
know what they're called and she came
home and she said my spirit animal first
of all she came through the door excited
and said I'm so excited of the best news
my spirit animal is a wild turkey
it doesn't seem good I said get out it's
over you know what I never I never
really thought we had a lot in common
and right now I might jump off my own
balcony I mean what is that anyway I
literally was like is this gonna be hard
for you around Thanksgiving and then she
didn't like that do you think that the
lady or the person who like chose that
told her the animal was like just has
like a long list is gonna give out the
same one over and over again so far down
unlike the things you think of yet she
is she's like smoking a long ticker and
she goes alright what let's see the last
[ __ ] like a magical pig uh then I get
saucy chicken I'm gonna go with wild
turkey just like in a muumuu sensible
pump what was it kidney kitten heels
full circle I mean full so that's your
spirit animal kitten heel kitten heel is
now my new spirit animal Julia write
that down uh this has been an absolute
joy I had a blast you're a joy um
alright so let's plug stuff us your
podcast yes listen to my podcast it's
called with special guest Lauren lapkus
and the premise of the podcast is that
I'm always the guests and my guess is
always the host so it's different every
time and the host decides what they want
the show to be and I'm in character and
they make up my character and they tell
you do characters yeah that's most of it
so amazing check it out on itunes in
Earwolf calm and you can follow me on
twitter at lauren lapkus and you can
watch me and jurassic world this summer
and i'm gonna be in a new TV s show and
you'll find out about that as gets
closer you're not doing enough for your
feel bored well congratulations on all
your success you're fantastic and were
new friends yes this was so fun um I am
gonna be in Michigan while she's in
Jurassic world I'm actually the sound
editor on that bouvet I should scream
out cut laughfest Gilda radner's laugh
fest in michigan next weekend Grand
Rapids get your coat on your sassy pants
or kitten heel I've got some new jokes
about how I can't handle my own anxiety
I'll be performing with probably a lot
of men so I might not wear a skirt and
scream out I love gamecocks just to fit
in Thank You sports without balls fans
have the best week of your life